il est possible aussi
rassembleuse quoi tous les matins elle
même fille avec 120
ce sens pour lui seul jour la paix
l'amour bel oui il est timide et elle
elle est si belle il ne veut pas y aller
il est connu au potentiel mais quoi lui
a souri quand elles étaient 110 et
depuis ce jour à el haddad heroku
ailleurs j allais
zig le monde sait aurait dû faire
crois moi on a tous dit à cet orage
assez dommage c'était de la terre
yasmina une belle mois elle et qu'elle
est douée navré de sa vie j'exerce muet
face à ces mails autre monde et à ses
pieds mais si lui répéter tout foirer
bettié fois elle s'imagine sous la
lumière des projecteurs à peine à
recevoir les compliments et les chefs la
mélasse me dérouiller coincé dans la
routine ça lui arrive de chanter quand
elle travaille à l'ucl il aurait dû y
aller
pas d'une souris à l'oreille tu crèves
crois moi qu'on a tous dit assez dommage
à 7 h
c'était là
dernière fois l'aurait dû y aller tu
fais
on a tout dit
john est affalé au fond du canapé il
engueule son petit frère quand il passe
devant la télé ses amis sont sortis ne
les a pas suivis comme semence la lune
viendra lui tenir compagnie way diego
est triste il ne veut rien faire de sa
nuit les primes neutre a trouvé la femme
de sa vie et poivre diego tu fais
tellement tromper c'est fait à cette
soirée que tu as et leur encontre
allez vous régaler
il aurait dû gère trois mois on a tous
dit il ya ces dommages assez dommage
c'était la guerre
combine elle est discrète elle oublie
qu'elle est belle elle a surtout le
corps des tâches de la couleur du ciel
son mari rande bientôt elle veut même
pas y penser quand il lui prend le bras
c'est pas pour la faire danser
elle repense à la mairie cette décision
qu'elle a prise à cet après midi où elle
a fait sa valise
elle avait un avenir un fils a élevé
après la dernière danse
elle s'est pas relevé elle aurait dû y
aller elle aurait dû le faire
crois moi on a tous dit à ces dommages
assez dommage c'est peut-être la
dernière fois on a tous dit assez
dommage à celle hommage à ces dommages
assez dommage ou pas c'est dommage
ah c'est dommage pour tous
tu fais
moi pour la saisie la fête
c'était la galère
m
dieu
croit on l'a dit à ses dommages assez
dommage c'était
vaut mieux vivre avec des remorques des
regrets pour mieux vivre avec des
remords pour mieux vivre avec des
regrets